these notes alpha plus beta alpha beta
and stuff those things ask you to put
the Box are called via page results is a
French mathematician who while it came
up with this and we're going to use the
end results to answer this question
along with some of the factorization
stuff in the family so they give you a
quadratic what's the UH what's the
quadrant again x squared is plus X plus
X and in the takeaway yet okay lunch one
equals zero that I yep so they give you
this okay and then they ask you for
alpha to the power 6 plus beta to the
power asleep that's the question where
alpha beta by the roots now you can see
why I showed you this in order to help
you with that
because how do you factorize it squared
plus X minus 1
what's that pair of does is that add to
1 and multiplies to negative 1
yeah I'm struggling to okay so I'm going
to be in trouble key to work out with
you are I should point out it is
possible but isn't it better if I could
work out like the different edges of the
question directly while be knowing about
some other way so I want you to think
back to the factorization stuff that you
see is a little mama I want you to think
I objects per video I'm going to give
you two or three visits to figure out
this yourself and also attention friends
and try and work out think about we were
looking at something really high powers
lastly do you remember that when I look
at some things where it's like oh my
goodness a ton power 32 what am I
supposed to do with that okay but
eventually we sort of more down and we
could work out what's happening you
don't have any power to you can tell
them there how could you possibly use
these building blocks to try and come up
with a plan
how to think about it all toys as like
she have a shot yourself
last week work last week's work was a
clue okay in the like you look at higher
powers and immediately drinking just a
recoil of life how you get that okay we
can get to that using the building block
if you think it means literally like
building blocks it's either like Lego
right like if you just have one of these
guys like you do you guys created in
such as item analysis or you know you're
like oh okay I can um I can do lots of
things of this like I can hope people
speak I can do pyramid these things are
powerful if you start with one if you
can add them up that you can create
incredible structures own complexity so
what I'm going to do is try and think
about this object in terms of those
here's the first thing I'm going to do I
noticed that even though this is a power
six color sticks you can write these
things as squares or cubes because 6 & 6
are both 5 9 1 2 or 3 maybe get remember
factors obviously the structure so if
for example I write this like zone alpha
cubed squared must be 2 cubed squared
that's just a nick was nothing
dramatically but now I can see I've got
the sum of two squares I know you how to
factorize the sum of two squares right
it was something we specifically looked
at last time it was an example of how to
make things Messier before they got
better if I showed you this and said hey
I want to get a perfect square out of
this what would you add to this to make
it a perfect square
yeah doing it exactly you recognize the
structure pretty well but of course if
you add something somewhere because it's
convenient to you you got made this
different so in order to preserve the
original question you have to subtract
it at the same time as adding does that
make sense
so have a look at this is in exactly the
same situation you've got two things in
there squared so what is it you need to
add to both of them in order to complete
that square what we're going to add I'll
give you a clue it's not for the two
just like that yes
yeah that's right you see the a and B in
this case are out two dimensions
okay so I'm going to write alpha cubed
be the cubes there but of course we can
add something in order to preserve your
expression
you'd better subtractive as well you
okay with that all right now all the
next one are not finished but you can
see progress which is important right
I'm now going to factorize these things
here I put them in place because they
will be a public square just like these
things here okay so it's going to be
something
and of course you can reverse if you're
not sure you can just reaffirm it did
you get back there and you've got this
guy over here now before I do really
like write you down I notice that this
is very quickly related to one of my
building blocks like you notice that I
can put together some amazing to get
this right come back to the original
clue let's say what these are let's just
look at the numbers right
in this case sorry in this case what's
my dispiriting minus B and the one
they're all a is just going to be
negative 101 which is just anyone what
about Alpha Beta the product of the
roots
yeah it's C on a which coincidentally
ends up being exactly the same thing
maybe important okay now how am I going
to get from this object here what do I
have to do to it in order to turn it
into this object
well for starters you notice I would
have to give it Majesty that is both
persecute that okay and now you can see
a way I do like this uh broom this is
just a number so I can just slot it in
not have to worry about all the
algebraic terms let's start to worry
about so I'm going to just simplify that
first together anyway
minus two times one we say that the
product was negative one right shoot
okay don't deal with that second have a
look again look at this object it's
better it's objectively better than what
I started with right so now think again
go back to your knowledge that you've
developed in last of the week what can
you do with this
some accuse some of the key that this is
one of the results that you looked at
once again they remember you should have
it bad but it tell me about my memories
right I'm pretty sure it alpha plus beta
alpha square minus alpha beer plus
meters but how about numbers I get it
now okay
by the way in case you're wondering
right to the example one when you have
to deal with this result Vixia even the
rivers which is topping your join us to
memorize this result we can't give it to
you in something called a reference
sheet because we have lots of formulas
you have to learn but Peter to poor
people who had to do that reformer and
shape dividing to memorize engines L
because fill the syllabus the way I
remember is if you have a look at these
signs which is a hard part to learn out
of this semester that you're quite easy
in the road I just remembered this
acronym the signs all relates to this
plus the first one we the same the next
one will be opposite and in the last one
is always positive doesn't matter
started so if we're examples is alpha
cubed minus b cubed and everything here
would be the same except the sign would
be same so negative opposite which is
positive and then the last one is quite
fun uh-huh
that's assignment in fact right into
successfully what's this you've all play
that there it is there because that's
their right this whole thing up back
ties the whole thing is being squared to
don't lose that okay
and the ki tamaki should evaluate what's
this going should become what's negative
one cute maybe one so they do minus two
times maybe one will just a plus issue
okay now have a look we've made even
more progress
alpha plus video I know exactly what
that is that's just negative one the
great and then you've got this thing
here look look should we do something
similar with this
like we did up here I can't Buster ages
is tone for what will I have to do to
okay if I subtract alpha beta from here
right watch what happens this is going
to be no longer take away one alpha be
done it's going to be take away 2 alpha
beer but of course you can't just take
away other bitter because you feel like
it we've got to make sure we preserve
the objects you took away that means
you've got to add it to compensate I'm
just going to shut down over here
is that okay live a long mass that you
agree with those are equivalent and then
that whole thing was squared and then
you had a two on yet okay why is this
helpful
what have I got to in here what is this
object alpha minus beta square now it's
going to pause remember this was a fine
factorization it works you factorize
them however in this case most helpful I
would like it to be why is that yeah I
was like oh I factorize
but it wasn't towards something that I
knew how to do it would be a little bit
like you look at um I am a ghost and
you're like oh cool I've worked out
exactly what I need to make this and
then you work out what pieces you need
and then you realize I don't have those
pieces I don't have that read like angle
shape or something like that so even
though this is factorized you can build
this from this this is not what I'm
doing box I have access to so that's
fine we've just sort of hit a brick wall
rerun delude come back to here what else
could I do okay so subtracting an alpha
beta Davis and this which we can
factorize but it didn't end up being
useful factorization no problem if I did
want the useful factorization I would
want this to be plus do you agree that
that would be something I could do with
more
right but what is it that you have to do
this to get to this you had to add add
do another color just so you can see the
law obviously I had to add 3 alpha
prenup in order to turn this into this a
following for what algebra if you can
see through it now that you know you had
to advocate this add 3 alpha beta what
do you do to call to say hey go away ok
now let's try again we try this when I
factorize it I don't end up with alpha
minus B Square I end up with alpha plus
B squared that's 1 right with this guy
hanging up on the end but I know what
this is fun look what is this equal to
this is minus 3 times negative 1 which
is plus 3 so you can see I just sort of
chip away at this as I discover blocks
that I have access to I can just
substitute the mouth closed Brown here
and then that squared plus 2 okay I'm
out of space there so understanding you
color but you guys can continue down if
you've got room now I'm almost there
I'm always there equals and there's a
minus sign here but I'm about to not
write it do you see why I don't have to
write this minus sign actually because
he gets squared so it really does
negative 1 times negative 1 which is
trivial okay so I'm going to stop
writing that but I can evaluate this
this alpha plus beta is just negative 1
squared is a plus a 3 there and then
this object is squared you care with
that plus 2
can you finish for me which all right
please tell me we can see this part
right if we go through all of this so
they're good they based that one maybe
set this is inside year one plus three
which is four